good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight when the russian
military invaded ukraine last month the
most highly credentialed people in the
world
seemed stunned by it and that was not
very reassuring to the rest of us quote
it was a shock to many of the leading
experts and policymakers in the united
states europe and even ukraine explained
a fellow expert and policymaker at the
atlantic council quote the head of
german intelligence was so caught off
guard that he was still in kiev and had
to be evacuated
that's pretty weird if you think about
it because for weeks joe biden had been
speaking in a very loud voice about a
potential russian invasion of ukraine
they seemed ready for it and yet it
turns out that nobody in washington
including biden himself really thought
it was going to happen
and when it did happen official
washington concluded that putin must be
insane
the casual speculation about vladimir
putin's mental state has become more
serious wrote national review
in other words there's a reason a good
reason none of us saw this coming putin
just snapped he's irrational and
impossible to predict
a lot of people took that at face value
but you had to notice that like most
explanations you hear in washington it
was self-exculpatory it was more an
excuse than an analysis
in fact putin may well be crazy but it's
fair to assume there was more to the
invasion of ukraine than a single
psychiatric episode and at this point it
would be nice to know exactly what it is
what happened and why why did the
russians do this
it's not treasonous to ask that it's
essential you can't make wise decisions
about the future without understanding
what just happened it's a prerequisite
but our leaders so far have refused to
do that they keep lying to themselves
they're imposing censorship on the rest
of us they're forcing the entire
american population to mouth childish
slogans about good versus evil
it's insulting but worse it's not
helpful
this is not how nations survive complex
moments like this crisis demands crystal
clear thinking
so now is the moment to ignore the
people who've been consistently wrong
and instead listen carefully to the
people who've gotten it right in the
past the ones who saw the ukraine more
coming and said so out loud
those are the people you should be
listening to and one of them is nigel
farage
nobody would call farage a stooge of
vladimir putin just the opposite farage
is a nationalist he cares about his own
country he's devoted his life to it in
his case his country is great britain
whose long-term interests have been
gravely damaged by the russian invasion
and by the west's response to it the
same is true unfortunately of our
country the us has never had a president
as reckless as joe biden is we're going
to pay the price for that for a long
time
but nigel farage had you asked him could
have predicted all of this in fact he
did predict it back in 2014 as the
leader of the uk independence party
farage gave a speech to the european
parliament that year which unfortunately
we just saw yesterday
in retrospect his words seem prophetic
farage understood what would happen
because he saw clearly what had already
taken place
watch this carefully we think you'll
agree it's an analysis worth hearing
here's nigel farage eight years ago on
ukraine
amongst the long lists of foreign policy
failures and contradictions in the last
few years including of course the
bombing of libya
the desire to arm the rebels in syria
has been the unnecessary provocation of
vladimir putin
this eu empire ever seeking to expand
stated its territorial claim on the
ukraine some years ago
uh just to make that worse of course
some nato members said they
they too would like the ukraine to join
nato we directly encouraged the uprising
in the ukraine that led to the toppling
of the president yanukovych
and that led of course in turn to
vladimir putin reacting and the moral of
the story
is if you poke the russian bear with a
stick
don't be surprised when he reacts
now
just to continue with that today we are
rushing through
an association agreement and undue speed
with the ukraine and as we speak
there are nato soldiers engaged in
military exercises in the ukraine have
we taken leave of our senses do we
actually want to have a war with putin
because if we do we're certainly going
about it the right way perhaps we ought
to recognize
that the west now faces the biggest
threat and crisis to our way of life
that we have seen for over 70 years the
recent beheadings of the british and
american hostages graphically
illustrates the problem and of course we
have our own citizens from our own
countries engaged in that struggle too
in the war against islamic extremism
vladimir putin whatever we may think of
him as a human being is actually on our
side i suggest we grow up i suggest we
recognize the real threat facing all of
our countries communities and societies
we stop playing war games in the ukraine
and we start to prepare a plan to help
countries like syria like iraq like
kenya like indeed nigeria to try and
help them to deal with the real threat
that faces us let's not go on provoking
putin whether we like him or not
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight